Mean Girls turns 15 today and we've got
the stories you never knew and the cast
looks back on their movie milestone the
15th anniversary of Mean Girls 15 years
oh my gosh
[Music]
see meanwhile still to me feels like it
was yesterday
that is so favorite memory from making
that incredible movie oh my gosh
shooting that movie I had never been in
a movie before and so I had no idea you
know I just done Weekend Update but
leave it aside some behind-the-scenes
secrets
well first Lindsay Lohan or Rachel
McAdams could have had each other's
roles what is happening to the world but
after Freaky Friday the filmmakers
didn't think fans would accept Lindsay
as a villain casting is perfect so it's
just I'm really excited Rachel needed to
go blind but she couldn't fully bleach
it so that was a wig I just sort of
thought that was very regina long blonde
Barbie hair Amanda Seyfried also tested
for Regina but was a better fit as ditzy
Karen I'm so skinny shut up it was
best time amanda was just 17 and check
out her total team reaction to Rachel's
next big gig I have a film coming up in
June called The Notebook that's Ryan
Gosling yeah yeah yeah like a regular
mom I'm a cool mom right Regina please
stop talking Amy Poehler played Rachel's
mom but she was only seven years older
in real life and James Franco was once
considered for Jonathan Bennett's part
well cool it wouldn't be the same
without him all right here's trivia for
you do you know what Mean Girls was
supposed to be called home-schooled it
just doesn't sound quite as me
[Music]
[Applause]